when I went to go I went to go perform
in Dallas and I'm just I'm featuring and
it was just a one-night feature and man
I mean I'm feeling like I'm the [ __ ]
like after I get off the stage they're
like we got a section for you too
you're like and we're know let this club
this is nothing like our section is
right next to the Cowboys like
quarterback like the quarterback is
their dak is there Ezekiel is there yeah
well we're right this woman though I'm
dancing and now you got a deck like
telling me like Oh bro keep that bro
like yeah you really he's offering me
drinks as [ __ ] and there's girls and
we're all dancing his bro I'm on like
cloud behind yeah yeah yeah right and
and then yeah I start flirting a little
too much to start just this snap
whatever right and so I get back home I
break over there
oh [ __ ] because I felt so guilty and
then I'm like oh she don't deserve this
at all yeah like I'm like like I got I
got really I got some [ __ ] that I gotta
[ __ ] take care of like this it's
ridiculous I'm tired of feeling like
[ __ ] right yeah and so she obviously
doesn't know why the [ __ ] I broke over
her right cuz I didn't want to expose
that to her cuz she obviously forgave me
already right and and so she ends up
like it's confused and all these things
and couple days go by we have two
bedrooms so I'm in my the other bedroom
and she comes to the room and she was
just like I can't I can't leave like she
was like she was telling me like I
really don't know I want to be with you
I can't leave like what is that what's
the problem yeah what's going on you
know what I mean and I told her I was
like I'm just tired of like hurting you
and at that point she was like what did
you do she's like she cleared it up yeah
I smell some [ __ ] wait I'm going on what
happened yeah and I was like I was doing
some extra [ __ ] out there in Dallas yeah
Abe Abe she was and that's what she
broke down again and then she but this
time she handled it differently it
wasn't like the first one yeah she
handled this one differently because she
was like she was like okay one do you
want to be with
let's get this out of the way do you
want to be with me let's figure this
[ __ ] out
yeah be real do you want to be with me I
said yes she's like why do you want to
be with me and I told her the reasons
why why why I want to be with you you
know you make me feel great I love how I
am go around each other
I love for the person that you are you
make me better I root for you you root
for me like we're we're really like
partners out here you know I mean like
we're really like that that feels great
that I haven't had before you know I'm
just like just let her know what it is
she's okay so she's like what is it
about when you go to a different city
than what it is here because when you're
here you're the best boyfriend I could
ask for
yeah I love you you're great right but
when you go to River City this [ __ ]
happens right so she's like what is it
and and shields I don't even know
[ __ ] buy your drugs and she was like
tell me what's up and I'll just like
when I'm in a different city I feel like
I'm the [ __ ] I feel like I'm the actual
like entertainer that I'm supposed to be
when I'm in LA I'm a boyfriend I'm a
screen printer I'm a designer and I do
websites and then I'm a comedian yeah
whenever I get booked yeah you know and
so and so I was like I feel like I died
like when when I get booked to it in a
different City I'm just in that city as
Christo so the end the comedian yeah you
know and this and that's and that's what
makes me feel like this is what I'm
supposed to be doing when I'm back home
it's like this is just [ __ ] you know and
I'm not not saying that our relationship
is [ __ ] I'm saying this isn't what I'm
out here like like this is what I was
rolling as she goes she goes well why
don't we work on you being the [ __ ] and
where you live so that when you go to a
dev or city you don't feel like you're
better you're just the same Chris yeah
and I'm like god damn it what's your
ring size how do you come up with this
yeah she was like she broke me down saw
all the [ __ ] you know and of course I
had to be completely honest of like
telling her no this is what's going on
with me like I'm not trying to [ __ ]
you I'm not even trying to win you back
because ours I broke up with you because
I know that you deserved better I guess
you know this whole thing and she broke
me down and she'll just like won't work
on that and then once I know ah man you
don't deserve her bro everybody's like
damn who is this woman
Oh bro Oh bro first of all first of all
this is the first platform ever talking
about this oh wow yeah I mean I got to
tell you this dope so I really tried I'm
really trying to make sure it is very uh
serious light not necessary it's what
I'm saying like yeah I don't wanna I
don't want her to be like keep it up she
don't have power she can't hear no she
does that's the misconception here she's
somebody who knows what she wants and
the great thing is is that she knows how
to communicate really [ __ ] well yeah
and the fact that she's invested into
you not because it doesn't seem like
she's invested you just because at the
time I think she could really she really
knows who you are as a person
yeah right and she understands that
humans are flawed and her choices to
stay with his person that she really
loves who is it who in her mind and
heart she knows is a good person yeah
and I think the communication that you
guys have is great as at this point more
on her side
right yes I think for you you're having
issues of number one guilt because you
do Glover you know it's it's a weird
space to be in right it's because you're
making these actions thinking that
you're doing something great for her you
know right and for her it doesn't work
out that way he's like no I what I want
is us for us to be committed and for you
to be open and communicate this to me
for you to just bounce is actually
opposite of what I feel like I deserve
yeah because in your mind you're
thinking you're doing something great
for her when it really had turns of
something for yourself because it's
eating you up inside
yeah and that's where it becomes really
confusing right it's like oh I think I'm
doing this for her just doing this for I
don't wanna feel guilty anymore so here
you go exactly
yeah it almost seems selfish but at the
same time it is very selfish mm-hm and
so for her I think the great thing about
her is that she she really knows how to
just talk to you yeah right and that's
the hard part yeah I think what most
people don't realize is that they think
that monogamous relationships are the
easiest thing to do right yeah it's
actually in my personal opinion it's the
harder route because it's easier just to
live freely without staying into a
single come
yeah most people can't even commit
themselves to a single [ __ ] career or
a job or a thought so what makes you
think that you could commit yourself to
one person for the rest of your life
yeah I think when you package things
right and you prepare yourself for that
you have to realize everything that that
entails yeah for me I like monogamous
relationships and this is what I have in
my head the reason why I like monogamous
relationships and having one person
there for me is because there's
something that I get from something like
your situation there's no way that you
would [ __ ] around with the girl and she
they would understand how you're saying
how you're feeling and what you want out
of life and just [ __ ] around with you
no [ __ ] way yeah you have to take
time and develop that stuff yeah for me
that's what I enjoy I enjoy the fact
that I had this person next to me that
understands me I don't have to
constantly explain myself I don't have
to dress the best all the time I don't
have to look a certain way on out the
smell a certain way just to harbor your
attention yeah she's just there and she
loves me for who I am that's the beauty
of a monogamous relationship right the
other side of that is that I think
naturally we want to be able to do the
things that we want without the weight
on our shoulders but then for me it's a
give-and-take it's like what are you
what do you find precious in your life
is are these glimpses are these moments
of you going on she's used the word
glimpse yeah she's use that yeah
whatever what are these moments are
these do you are you are you are you
living for these moments or or or these
things or just little diesel moments
yeah yeah and and I went with that one
yeah man and and I guess it's easier for
me to talk about now because she did
make her first little joke yeah you know
she did her first little jab yeah I
don't know maybe like a couple months
ago you know it's funny is that I added
on to the joke it was like okay we're
not there yet [ __ ] sit yeah man yeah
she's bro she's a solid girl and this
was something that uh even kept a Kevin
on they wanted to talk about on the love
our about how we're working through this
you know I mean and I've talked to my
girl about it and she was she was like
honestly it's a row even more thinking
about me she was like this she was like
honestly it's all up to you on how you
feel if people are gonna view if you're
cool with like any type of judgments
then she's like I mean I don't mind
talking about it we can we could do it I
like this though because it's the reason
why I like this so much is because
there's a lot of people out there that
have done what you've done but they're
so good at lying about it bro that's
what I'm saying I'm like why can't I be
like y'all now saying I don't want to do
this anymore I'm saying I'm saying I'm
talking about like bro I faced I've
tried to yeah my homies I can get away
we date or this person gets away with it
and when I tried to live that life bro
what like this this is how I know I'm a
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] cheater